have you guys seen the documentary push
no you have to is it like push with get
Gabrielle Sidibe it's no was that movie
it's a documentary on Netflix Gabourey
Sidibe is that it's precious that's
precious not push let's go Barney
it's Geisel there's a lot of confusion
here let's say let's go okay push is a
documentary about a a man he's a
Mentalist and they conduct an experiment
basically where they're trying to
they're trying to prove or they're
trying to see if you can take any
ordinary nice individual and and have
fun convinced them to commit a murder
and basically that's basically what it
is it's a social experiment they
captured on film they get for people to
you know comply and three don't ruin it
if you haven't watched it definitely
watch it and they audition a bunch of
people and they test each person's level
of compliance yeah so that's the thing
that's how they choose their people
there are people who are naturally more
compliant than others and when Bobby and
I were watching it we were like Oh we'd
be out we would never be what yeah we
would be out I'm not complaining because
we're such skeptics we're like why the
[ __ ] are you doing that there are people
there that work that because there's
Authority saying to do something they
just do it now or when the masses do
some an act they just do it without
thought because it's they don't want
they want to blend in give the example
of the sitting up in there right so yeah
so they so they they go hey this guy
this mental is famous in England he was
like I have a new show I want people to
you know audition for or sign up for it
so hundreds of people showed up and what
they did is they conducted a experiment
they had the first so they basically
brought people in to fill out forms but
the first four people that were in there
were actors
so like the 16 people that come in so
they're all in a seat and they have a
bell
and when the bell goes off the three
actors stand up when the Bell they hear
the bell and they sit down but they're
still filling out the form so that these
people can come in these are not people
that are that want to be on the show and
they're filling out forms also some of
them stand up with these three actors
when the béla happens those are the
compliant ones they don't know why
they're doing it but they just doing it
because they have to do it because they
hear this Bell and they're just gonna do
or they see some people doing it so
they're like pocket some people are just
like a [ __ ] that I'm understanding well
I wouldn't no one told me to stand yeah
they just fill out the form sitting down
those are the ones that were like taken
out of the room right apply it so all of
the compliant ones they find the four
most compliant and those are the ones
months later they don't even know but
they're tricked into this thing into the
scenario where there's like 200 actors
in a building and at the very end of it
the person has to decide whether or not
they want to push someone down the
building and there's a real person at
the edge of a building and these these
four people you get to see whether or
not they push that person it's pretty
brilliant pretty crazy
yeah whoa yeah and then afterwards
they're like you know they talked about
it but um it's a crazy it's not that
long like an hour an hour long after
seeing the process do you guys feel like
you would have been compliant hell yeah
[ __ ] mind I'm asking never kill
anybody for no [ __ ] reason at all I
think that him and I question things too
much wait wait your face is now you
showered no reason at all oh that's
that's there's too many reasons okay
give me a scenario that that would kill
somebody then somebody took Dobby
somebody threw Grobe off the roof push
push that [ __ ] down so Mikey all
right so I'm up in the roof mm-hmm you
just pick up goby and you throw off the
roof and kill him
my dog Jesus George I would probably I
would probably grab your hair and truck
me kick your face like bu up and go what
the [ __ ] yeah I would scream like what
the [ __ ]
for right and I would go I'm calling the
cops
howdy foamy just up the edge of the roof
just at the edge of the roof I would not
kill you for that
I want to kill anybody for anything all
right do your what you know why somebody
had Steve hostage and like okay this is
the only scenario you're dumb you're bad
at this this is what you do this is this
is what happens there was like you
you're on a video right there you go hey
Bob I have Steve tied up and you take a
gun and you blow my brother's brains
Jesus right on Kenneth right then I
would hunt you down kill you okay but
that's not what this [ __ ] thing is I
also think that [ __ ] you man you don't
know what [ __ ] you're gonna kill my
brother you [ __ ] [ __ ] so dark
George asked for it yeah but I want oh
my god Oh God have you said that what
you say there was a scenario which no no
you didn't win you lose
okay you shaved your beard and you look
dumb you switch your [ __ ] outfits
white to [ __ ] blue and you lose you
their hair cut your skin color you lose
your loser all right like you you're
free [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ] don't
ever challenge me I love you thank you
for helping us produce this look too
Bobby
[Music]